so tonight Ron DeSantis will announce
his candidacy he has the audacity
to challenge Donald Trump's path to the
2024 Republican nomination Donald Trump
wasting no time and starting to post
even engaging caps lock to truth social
truth essential Trump posting as news
broke of Ron desantis's impending
candidacy quote look Rob de
sanctimonious came to me asking for help
he was losing badly by 31 points to
popular agriculture commissioner Adam
Putnam he was getting ready to drop out
of the race ran a terrible campaign Ron
told me he had one last chance my
support and endorsement which Putnam and
everyone else wanted also I gave it to
Ron and the race was over in one day he
went from losing badly to winning by a
lot it actually took four months but
okay who cares about the details with
three large Trump rallies he won the
general election in an upset disloyal
yeah
this is how Trump sees everything not
just politics and many Republicans see
it this way although maybe not to the
degree that Trump does I did something
for you
and now you should essentially have a
loyalty that is almost an indentured
servitude to me for the rest of your
political career you should never ever
ever run against me because I helped you
and and uh that is the sort of moral
Foundation to the extent that it is one
for Donald Trump trump continuing on
truth and then engaging caps lock here
quote Rhonda Sanctus can't win the
general election or get the nomination
because he voted to obliterate Social
Security even wanting to raise the
minimum age to 70 or more voted to badly
wound Medicare and fought hard and voted
for a 23 tax on everything sales tax he
wasn't is a disciple of horrible Rhino
Paul Ryan and others too many to mention
also he desperately needs a personality
transplant that's true and to the best
of my knowledge they are not medically
available yet a disloyal person Trump
then continuing in all capital letters I
built the greatest economy in the
history of the world no inflation energy
Independence and soon dominance the
strongest border ever record best
employment numbers biggest tax and
regulation Cuts rebuilt our military no
Wars with Russia Ukraine or China Taiwan
or anywhere and the U.S was respected
all over the world what else can I say
almost everything there is a lie and
then one more truth all caps short and
sweet election interference so if Trump
is this triggered by the news that
DeSantis will be announcing his
candidacy tonight just you wait for what
Trump is going to do after tonight's
announcement this is going to be one of
the ugliest Republican primaries
that I've ever covered certainly but
maybe for an even longer period than
that I would expect videos I would
expect the tax interviews Furious
interviews hopefully with significant
audio trouble that's always the best but
we will be following all of it and I
hope you'll join me tonight shortly
before 6 PM Eastern 3 P.M Pacific we
will be covering the DeSantis
announcement
with Elon Musk Trump will probably
attack Elon Musk tonight as well uh it's
going to be wild and again the political
objective for me is for the ugliness of
the forthcoming Republican primary to be
as damaging as possible to whoever
eventually becomes the Republican
nominee likely Trump but maybe not also
Monday Memorial Day this is it guys
we're we're gonna do it Monday Memorial
Day we are launching a one-day
membership special as many of you know
membership is the primary funding source
for this program we are going to
discount membership in order to entice
people hopefully you to sign up on
Monday all you need to do to take
advantage of this membership special is
get on my newsletter that's really it
you don't need to get anything notarized
you don't need to send any smoke signals
or fax anything anywhere you don't need
to build a Lego uh train or anything
like that you simply get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com Monday
more morning you'll be notified and then
everyone will be winning
if you deal with anxiety or depression
you may have tried meditation exercise
diet changes therapy all of which are
important things to try there is also a
new treatment that we've been talking
about on the program for years which for
many people has been a game changer and
that is ketamine therapy the research
around ketamine therapy for anxiety and
depression looks very promising which is
why I'm thrilled about our new sponsor
mind Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people with anxiety
and depression it's delivered to your
door it's done from the comfort of your
home and unlike traditional talk therapy
ketamine Works quickly and doesn't have
the unpleasant side effects of
traditional antidepressants in a study
of over 1200 mind Bloom clients 89
reported improve movements in their
anxiety and depression after just two
sessions read about the evidence for
ketamine therapy we've talked about it
on the show it's pretty remarkable stuff
mind Bloom is offering my audience a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program
go to mindbloom.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description